let's talk about John Kelly there is
this idea that chief of staff John Kelly
is the adult in the room the reasonable
guy in the Trump administration who
avoids gaffes and understands what an
administration should look like and he
was going to be the guy to get the
riffraff out of crumbs administration
and it turns out that he's actually as
big a part of the riffraff as anybody
else he is now off the deep end recently
he said that the Civil War happened not
because the Confederacy wanted slavery
but because of a lack of ability to
compromise what a quaint lovely little
explanation for the Civil War right
Monday night most news media was
correctly reporting the major story that
multiple Donald Trump campaign officials
had been indicted for serious crimes not
Fox News's Laura Ingraham though Laura
Ingraham now has a show on Fox News she
was running a fluff interview with John
Kelly but part of that interview was
really wacky when John Kelly stated that
the civil war was because of a lack of
compromise and he said that also robert
e lee was a really honorable confederate
general i would tell you that robert e
lee was an honorable man he was a man
that gave up gave up his country to
fight for his state which in 150 years
ago was more important than country it
was always loyalty to state first back
in those days now it's different today
but the the lack of an ability to
compromise led to the civil war and men
and women of good faith on both sides
made their stand where their conscience
had them make their stand do we know if
John Kelly's from Boston I kind of am
hearing a Boston accent and Kelly
talking about it I mean it's probably
just a matter of looking it up but I've
never cared enough to actually do it
so Robert Ely was honorable and lack of
compromise was the problem not white
people wanting to own black people that
wasn't actually the reason for the Civil
War consider what this means when this
guy is the voice of reason in the Trump
administration who thinks Confederate
General Robert E Lee was honorable in
the Civil War was about lack of
compromise no historian agrees with this
it's just nonsense and the White House
is digging
deeper and deeper holes to defend this
garbage and there are actually some
people saying that Kelly was right here
if only Abraham Lincoln was willing to
compromise on the south having slaves we
would have avoided this and the stunni
thing is that the the sort of sick irony
of this is that Lincoln kind of was
willing to compromise on slavery
Lincoln's focus in the lead-up to the
Civil War was to stop the spread of
slavery but not to eliminate it
altogether but it was the Confederacy
who couldn't accept that fundamentally
and the Civil War was about them wanting
slaves now you can say as some people do
well it was about states rights it was
about states rights in the sense that
they wanted a state to have the right to
own slaves legally right you can say it
was about lack of compromise but it was
only about lack of compromise in the
sense that the south would not accept
anything but full and total legal
slavery period and we've learned that
John Kelly is only the adult in the room
in the way that an 8 year old seems like
the adult in the room when you've got a
2 year old using their pants as a
bathroom right only compared to the 2
year old does the 8 year old actually
seem like the adult in the room and I
think that's a pretty apt analogy for
chief of staff John Kelly now the upside
is if there is one that it seems like
the entire the Civil War wasn't about
slavery cult is slowly and sometimes it
seems like it's really slow slowly but
surely kind of drying up even though
recently it's been a little bit
emboldened by the Trump presidency in
the big picture that cult of people
saying that the Civil War as far as the
Confederacy was concerned with some kind
of great moral crusade on the up and up
for the betterment of our country or
something along those lines those people
are being relegated to the darkest
recesses of the internet and Civil War
reenactments in some southern states but
overall that those ideas are dissipating
and I think we can all be glad about
that discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our EDD i.t
we will take a break dr. robert lustig
joins me next today's episode of the
david
and show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription
into I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS